[موسيقى]
كيف ينظر الشارع العربي الى القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين في جده سالنا بدايه
الشارع السعودي عن دور الرياض المستمر في
راس الصدع العربي نشاهد
السعوديه
او الدول الاجنبيه بالذات الدول الشقيقه
العربيه السعوديه تقوم بدور جبار وعظيم
لحل المشاكل السياسيه والاقتصاديه دائما
سباكه في حل خلافاتها بين الدول ان كان في
ازمه اليمن ان كان في ازمه السودان وان
كان في ازمه فلسطين
[موسيقى]
مصر تمر بازمه اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه
بالاضافه الى خلاف مع اثيوبيا فيما يتعلق
بسد النهضه والامن المائي هل المصريون
متفائلون ان تمد لهم قمه جده يد العون
احنا بنتطلع ان العربي يساعدونا
في يعني الازمه الاقتصاديه احنا الازمه
الاقتصاديه طبعا زي ما بنطلع من الاخوه
العرب يعني دايما يسندونا ولكن احنا لازم
نسند نفسينا لا بصراحه لان لو كانت هتساعد
كان سعد قبل كده في القيم العربيه السابقه
يعني بنتمنى اللي هو يتحل يعني ونتملى
يبقى الحل على على ايدين الاجتماع اللي
هيحصل ونتمنى يبقى السعوديه وش الخير يعني
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
يعيشوا لبنان ازمه ماليه خانقه واخرى
سياسيه تتمثل بانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه ما
رايك الشارع اللبناني حول قدره القمه
العربيه على مساعده بلادهم
استثنائيه بمكان استثنائي بقياده
استثنائيه واليوم الدوره عم تلعبو المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على المستوى العربي لم
الشمل هذا بالنسبه لنا شيء حدث تاريخي
المهم انه يتفقوا مع بعضهم للشعب يرتاح
عرفت كيف لانه البلد ما بقى بيتحمل انت
بدك مساعده حالك ما حدا بيساعدك
اما العراق فيشهدوا تجاذبات سياسيه
واقتصاديه عده لكنه بدا يعود تدريجيا الى
المشهد العربي سياسيا واقتصاديا الشارع
العراقي هل يعول على القمه العربيه الثاني
والثلاثين في جده الكثير دعونا نشاهد
اما بالسعوديه يعني انا اعتبرها هذا
انتصار للامه العربيه بكاملها لانه الان
خاصه القمه راح تتم بوضع العراق وضعه
سياسي وضع الاقتصادي وهاي مبادره حلوه من
اخوتنا السعوديين في هذا المجال لان
السعوديه دائما تدعم الشعب العربي جميعا
وهذا مبادره كلش جيده نتامل من السعوديه
خير
للعراق وتتعاون وهي بادرت باكثر من مشروع
تجاري او زراعي او كهربائي
[موسيقى]
امل كبيره يعقدها الشارع العربي على القمه
العربيه في جده لانهاء الازمات
المدمم العربي وسط تفاؤل حذر يبديه البعض
تجاه هذه القمه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مدينه جده العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات